Uma is the coolest villain kid on the
aisle she's a strong leader with a big
ax to grind
we know that she has some diabolical
plans for mal and her crew in d3 but
what will happen to Emma after that will
she become good or stay true to her evil
routes watch until the end to find out
that snooty little witch who grabbed
everything she wanted and left me
nothing descendants 3 we've seen the
costumes and incredible makeovers the
BK's will be sporting come descendants 3
but what about the story from the
teasers the new trailer and some leaked
set pictures we know that a lot is about
to go down it's pretty clear that mal
will be reunited in some way with her
dad looking at the trailer it's apparent
that the V Ches will be facing their
most epic battle yet from the set fix we
know that a seemingly good kid turns bad
Audrey is back and she's decked out in a
wicked costume and punk rock pink hair
her head is tilted back in a nefarious
fit of laughter she's got Maleficent
staff and from the look on chad
Charming's face she is up to no good
in an interview dove Cameron teased that
deep three ties up all the loose ends
however she added that it's not
necessarily the end of the series while
we don't know exactly what's in store
for the characters in descendants three
we think there will be a lot of
unexpected moments involving the
conniving sea witch of the aisle
uma but in order to know where someone
is going we have to look at where
they've been Loomis origin uma Dorjan
story is similar to the other villain
kids uma has an evil parent who has
tried to corrupt her from an early age
none of the villain kids got much love
from their parents growing up
Ursula's lack of presence in umas life
is apparent in the descendants movies in
fact we've only ever seen her tentacle
slither out from behind a wall to try
and slap Emma and her mates
Ursula tells Emma and her friends to
shut their clams then Ursula reminds
Emma that the dishes aren't going to
wash themselves so it's safe to say that
uma grew up in unless the nurturing
environment it's clear that uma is
seeking power because she has felt
powerless all of her life she tells Ben
that her mom doesn't care about her and
that she can only do
and on herself that is so sad we almost
feel bad for her
could all of whom as despicable behavior
be due to a lack of love from her mother
still as Molly V Carlos NJ discovered
once out from under the oppressive
thumbs of their parents you can always
choose a different path so what if Emma
actually gets off the aisle and away
from her mother's control will she
choose to be good watch until the end to
find out final battle there is a lot to
unpack in the latest d3 trailer it looks
like mal and her crew are back on the
Isle and they are facing some sort of
armored army we see a shot of uma
holding a glowing blue jewel and we know
that there is going to be an epic battle
but it's unclear who will be fighting if
you watch the trailer closely you'll see
that uma Harry and Gil are wielding
swords to face those same armored dudes
from the beginning of the trailer you
know the ones at mal Evie Carlos and
Jake were fighting so it's possible that
uma is teaming up with mal and her crew
to fight an even bigger enemy or maybe
uma possessed the whole crew and they
are fighting the Knights of auradon it
doesn't seem likely that you would find
such fancy armor on the aisle and if you
look at their surroundings during the
battle it's clear that they are at our
Don prep so that means uma made it off
the island and is on auradon soil so is
she turning the other villain kids evil
or will she be the one to change from
this picture of mal and uma it looks
like they are becoming friends but Evie
doesn't look convinced that uma has
changed so it looks like not everyone is
fooled by umas change of heart what's
next for uma while we don't know exactly
what to expect for uma and e3 we've got
some predictions about what will happen
to her after the movie let's just say
that our theories are very similar to
other fan theories but with a few
important twists Lumas love interest
many fans predict that uma will hook up
with Harry hook they've got a smoking
chemistry in t2 so it's an obvious
connection the guy practically worships
her there is so much love in his eyes
when he is saying her name uma likes to
boss Harry around and Harry seems to
like it he is always down for whatever
terrible plot she cooks up he totally
gets the pirate and
life we could see this working out for
the two of them one fan thinks that uma
and Harry will have twin daughters named
Ursuline or Ania and a son named Hartley
his super specific one fan posted that
Ben seems to feel for uma more than he
ever did for mal during their talk on
uma ship he seems to genuinely care for
her and uma is always up front she tells
it like it is which is different than
mal a fan pointed out that mal hid
things from Ben and that uma would never
do that in the trailer we see that been
turned into a beast just like his father
so could he be turning evil as well
maybe uma is the only one who will
accept Ben as his beastly self so what
have Ben decides to join forces with uma
and take over our Don together with her
if they had kids they could be hairy
beasts with tentacles Wow that would be
interesting to see so let's say that
after d3 then enumerative ours on a bed
an uma ship would change the future of
our don forever however fans don't know
who to pick Ben or Gill uma and Gill
it's hard to imagine uma with anyone
else but Gill but hey anything can
happen right if Emma does indeed turn
out to be good this could pose a problem
between her and Gill
after all if he enjoys being a villain
why would he want to marry a hero so for
these two to work out they would have to
be on the same page so let's pretend
that Gill turns out to be a good guy as
well uma and now could resolve their
differences and become fast friends
after helping the BK's destroy their
common enemy Ben will pardon Emma and
Gill and they'll move to our dime we
love Gill and him went together but some
fans much prefer the uma and Ben ship so
let's entertain this theory for the hell
of it
look if Ben Enuma come together to rule
our dime uma will have to dress more
like royalty she'll need to give up the
scallywag swag look for some finer gowns
but we think there will always be an
element of the sea in Emma's look even
if emma is wearing the fancy attire in
auradon there will surely be some
scuffed up pirate boots underneath her
gown uma will give up her braid tiara
for the gold and blue crown but she will
keep the Blue Mermaid
staying true to her pirate roots will be
important to her so we imagine a lot of
rings necklaces and jewelry on her at
all times she will love having all the
treasure at her fingertips
we know that uma has a flair for drama
chances are she'll change the entire
look of the whole kingdom it will have
her signature blue with some darker gold
and silver accents OVA will be looking
fierce and so will the kingdom career
prospects so it's clear that uma is
resourceful she has strong leadership
qualities all of these characteristics
will come in handy if she rules or Adhan
as the future Queen instead of a
coronation uma will probably have a big
pirate bash we can just picture Harry
and Gil swinging from the ropes singing
loudly and dancing on the tables but
after the excitement fades she will have
to make a new life with them they will
learn what it means to rule auradon as
king and queen but will Emma be good or
evil if she is still evil what will it
mean for the fate of auradon does she
have been under another spell if so how
long can it last
or maybe she is just pretending to be
good when really she plans to overthrow
Arden and turn it into a Villains
playground
we've got more on that at the end of
this video
my mom doesn't care about me either not
unless you need someone for the
nightshift
Ursula it's obvious that uma does not
have a great relationship with her
mother but if emma takes over the aisle
and auradon that could change at that
point Ursula will probably do anything
to stay in her favor
Ursula might become proud of uma for
doing what she could never do herself
but it's more likely that Ursula would
become bitter and jealous if emma and
then get married
Ursula would be a difficult
mother-in-law but if they have kids
Ursula may change your tune and become
more loving than she ever was with uma
if Emma and Ursula work out their
differences will loom and aside to
denounce her evil roots and become good
or will Emma try to team up with her
mother to destroy their enemies that
brings us to our final prediction on
whether or not
uma will become good once evil always
evil we know that statement has proven
to be phosphor mal evj and Carlos but
will the same be true for uma the
trailer shows that
goes back to our Adan in d3 when the
other villain kids saw how great life
could be in auradon they changed they
decided to give up their old evil ways
and become good if OMA gets away from
the control of her mother and the bad
influence of the Isle
maybe she'll want a different life too
Ben seems to be very good but will he
change when he turns into a beast we all
know how surly his father became when he
was cursed as a beast so here is our
prediction uma and Ben joined forces to
take over our don uma only pretended to
be good so she could gain power and
trick the other B case she gets together
with Ben who was struggling with his new
beastly form uma convinces Ben to turn
to the dark side they take down the
barrier to the isle and rule over both
lands uma and then run the original
descendant kids off the isle they turn
our Adan crap into a school of dark
magic mal evey Carlos and Jay are
banished
it's umas way of paying them back for
keeping her locked on the Isle she puts
them on an even smaller island with a
stronger barrier you have to find a way
to escape and take back our Don then uma
and their family live terribly after so
wicked how do you think uma will end up
with thanks for watching the things did
you like this theory video if so click
the thumbs up button and subscribe and
don't forget to hit the notification
bell to be the first to see our latest
videos see you next time
[Music]